well now it's time for my smart glasses
and the final thought endless think
pieces have spilt ink over the question
of president Trump's tweeting it
occasionally undercuts his policy
priorities contradicts his cabinet
members and campaign surrogates even
occasionally raises the prospect of
legal trouble but hurricane Harvey
exposes all those worries for mere
trifles president Trump's attention to
the natural disaster and more
importantly coordination with local and
state first responders has been a table
and admirably but we should remember
that President Bush comported himself
relatively well during Hurricane Katrina
as well despite the utterly failed
response of local governments in a
barrage of unfair negative press the
difference today is that president
Trump's side steps the mainstream media
to speak directly to the American people
and show them what he and his
administration are doing without the
filter of Democrat operatives who
masquerade as journalists that direct
communication has even made the
mainstream media in this case bend the
knee and admit that the president is
doing well miracles abound
so keep tweeting mr. president and you
said it once I'll say it again and again
and again despite the constant negative
press
cough fa I'm Michael Moses the Mike
O'Connell show come back tomorrow we'll
do it all again
[Music]